FERHAT BUYUKKOTKTEN:
Hi, everyone.
I'm Ferhat.
Matan and I are leading the
Angular Dart effort at Google.
And we're very happy
to be with you today
to share what we've been
working on inside Angular Dart.
And we're going to introduce
today some new tools
to help you build
great web applications.
And Angular Dart-- these
are the three big pillars
that we think of when we're
working on Angular Dart.
Basically, any new
feature we add,
or when we make
changes in the APIs,
we try to make sure we
have a perfect balance
between these three items.
So on the productivity
side, we started
doing surveys inside Google.
Now our customer base or
the number of developers
are substantial enough, so
we're getting a lot of data
on productivity inside Google.
Performance wise,
we have now hundreds
of benchmarks on the
components and actual apps
running in production.
So if that material
button gets just 5%
slower somehow, because
we made the change--
MATAN LUREY: We
don't get emailed.
FERHAT BUYUKKOTKTEN: Yeah,
we immediately get an alert.
Basically it will
say, this exact
change-- you affected these
benchmarks across the stack.
And then we either roll back or
look at the issue and fix it.
So this allows our teams to
have a predictable and stable
framework under them,
because we want to make sure
once they ship these
into production,
the apps stay
stable and they keep
on running at high performance.
So about stability--
since last summer
we've been working with
these large Google teams
to get Angular Dart
into production.
And at this point,
we have monitored,
talked to a lot of
these teams, and looked
at the problems they were
having in terms of productivity,
worked through some of the
APIs, made them better.
And as Dan mentioned,
basically we
think we're ready for you
to start building production
apps today.
So we're happy to
release it today.
This morning we published
the new package.
So you can update your pubspec,
remove that beta from it,
and starts using it today.
MATAN LUREY: So how many
people here have written a web
application before in Dart?
Can I get a show of hands?
How many written
an Angular Dart?
Pretty good, actually.
This currently is our
workflow for Angular Dart.
I think it's actually one of the
best workflows for a web app.
This is how easy it
is to get started.
You get WebStorm with
your favorite IDE.
You write a little bit of code.
You hit Pub Serve,
and you Refresh.
There is no other set up,
no other dependencies,
nothing else.
It's actually really this easy.
You can do it in
five seconds, and I
think this is an awesome
experience for Angular Dart.
FERHAT BUYUKKOTKTEN:
So for those of you
who are new to
Angular, people love
Angular for its ease of
use and productivity.
Basically your HTML and
CSS is front and center.
So you just simply
edit an HTML file,
and then you write a Dart class,
which becomes your component.
And then you wire
up your template.
So it's a very easy model
to get started with.
And this is a typical Dart app.
Basically, you just
import the library, set up
your component-- in this
case, I have a single property
I'm binding to-- and then
you bootstrap your app,
and you're up and running.
So people love how easy it is
to get started in Angular Dart
and start building
web applications.
So Angular Dart
is also very deep.
So once your application
starts growing,
to give it better
structure, Angular Dart
provides dependency injection.
So you can start moving some of
the services, some of the data
layers, out of your views.
And you can simply inject these
services into your components.
And so that's on
the component side.
And on the template
side, it provides
a system called Directives
where you can basically
define behaviors.
You can extend the
language of the templates.
So you can create new
elements that expand the DSL
and allow you to build really
powerful libraries that you
can reuse across your app.
And injection is real easy.
You just create a Dart class,
MyService, put Add Injectable
on it, and it's ready for use.
Now I can take that
MyService and just
inject it in my constructor
on the main component.
This makes it very
easy to build tests.
Matan, later on,
will be showing you
how much nicer it is now to
test Angular Dart applications.
And for directives, essentially
you define a selector.
In this case, it
could be auto focus.
So whenever your
view gets created,
it will focus on the element
we have this directive on.
MATAN LUREY: So a big part of
why we actually like Angular
and why Angular likes
Dart, we are really
trying to use all of
those great core library
features that Dan and
Cathy talked about.
So Angular Dart is
all about streams,
zones, futures, the
collection library.
We're not inventing new things.
If you're comfortable writing
frameworks or apps in Dart
HTML-- and we saw last
night that a lot of people
wrote their own frameworks
with Dart HTML--
we're using the
exact same thing.
So it's streams.
It's futures.
It's all these core libraries.
You can open the code.
It's not something special.
So it's really exciting.
FERHAT BUYUKKOTKTEN: And the
big change in Angular 2.0
is that we're compiling
templates now.
And compiling templates
has very good properties.
So the first one is
faster DOM construction.
So traditionally, the way we
constructed DOM in Angular 1
and before is we would
essentially take the template
and then build it
inside the DOM.
And then we would clone that
tree of DOM nodes at runtime.
But of course, since we
have bindings and attributes
on those DOM nodes,
we would have
to go back, get the references
of each of those DOM elements,
and then update the attributes.
What compiled
templates lets us do
is we can actually write
code as if a human wrote it.
So we made some of these
changes over the past two,
three months.
If you look at the generated
template, that Dart code,
you'll see it writing
document dot create element,
and it will put the
tag name in there.
So it's very
readable now the way
we are generating
these templates.
And it is powered by the
Dart HTML library underneath.
So it's very familiar.
Whenever you want to
debug a component,
you can simply go into
the template Dart file,
and you can put a break point.
And it will look
familiar to you.
The other property compiled
templates have is we
started typing the members
we have in those template
dot Dart files.
If you open it up today, if
you use an input element,
and you have a value
property on it,
the input element is
now completely typed
in the Dart version.
So if you have value property,
it'll just set the value.
If you try to use it on a
development, at compile time,
it will say the
development class doesn't
contain the property value.
So at compile time, we
can do these tricks.
The same thing with
your expressions--
if you use a binding
expression and recompile it
into Dart code, at compile time,
you're going to get errors.
So the other cool
thing about compiling
is we get zero
cost abstractions.
So traditionally, Angular
had done all these things
at runtime.
For example, at
runtime, it would check,
am I running in debug mode?
Or am I running in release mode?
And it would select
debug or release
versions of those classes,
dynamically at runtime.
Of course--
MATAN LUREY: Imagine
hundreds of "if" statements.
Every single part of the code,
if debug this-- everywhere
throughout your code.
FERHAT BUYUKKOTKTEN: Yeah.
And what we're
able to do is we're
able to essentially now
target the exact release mode
or debug and generate
different code.
If you go to your pub spec
and change [INAUDIBLE] mode
to release or debug and
look at the template again,
you'll see how much smaller
the release versions are.
And then the debug
versions, it's
adding more debug info for you.
So if anything goes
wrong in your code,
you get better [INAUDIBLE].
Another good example for
this is because we're
compiling, at
compile time, we know
that a template reference
or an element reference
is actually just a
field on the view.
So we can directly pass
it into the constructor.
At runtime, we don't have to
look up-- in the injector--
look up in a map and
get these references.
So we can make injection
faster, because at compile time,
we already know about
these abstractions.
So a lesser known attribute
of compiled templates
is actually security.
So we're not doing any
evals anymore at runtime.
So we take your expressions,
we compile them into Dart code,
and now you can't inject
another function in there
or try to attack
the applications.
So this is very good
security properties.
Our security team at
Google loves that we're now
compiling these templates.
So of course, compiled
templates come at a cost.
And the cost is code size.
We're generating more code.
The traditional take
an HTML snippet,
that string actually
compresses really, really well.
But now we're
generating Dart code.
So we've started working
hard on this code size issue.
And this is a graph from one
of our code size benchmarks.
And this one dropped from 1.56
megabytes to under a meg now.
So we got 40% less
Dart code generated now
without changing
anything in Angular.
And we're not done yet.
There are some big
gains to be made still
on the code size side.
So how did we do it?
How did we drop 40%?
Well, first of all, as
you know, Angular Dart
is a separate repo now from
the TypeScript version.
So we started using
idiomatic Dart code when
we generate this compiled code.
So one of the examples
are we removed this dot
from all of the code generation.
And that gave us 8%.
So that means when you're
writing code today,
you're typing 8%
less code because you
don't have to do this
dot everywhere in Dart.
It's wonderful.
And all the other properties
that we love about
Dart-- the terseness of it,
as Dan mentioned in his talk--
we started using them
in the templates itself.
So that reduced the cost.
And we also started removing
all the dynamic calls.
So when Dart to JS
compiles it to JavaScript,
it doesn't have to check
the classes at runtime.
It generates much, much
tighter and more efficient
JavaScript code.
And as I mentioned
before, we started
removing abstraction layers.
So to us, Angular Dart
is perfect for the web.
And our main focus is
actually web development.
So we don't have to
have extra layers
for mobile native bindings
and things like that.
So tomorrow's talk is going
to show you a great framework
to do mobile development.
So in Angular Dart, we're
now able to take out
a lot of layers that
were in between to turn
Angular more into a platform.
We are concentrated
completely on the web
to create a great desktop
and mobile web applications.
Another change we did is
whitespace compression.
Some of you might be
familiar with the HTML spec
where if you have
two inline blocks,
it actually matters whether
you have space in between them
or not.
The browser is going
to basically layout
your HTML slightly differently.
But very few people
use this property.
And it's one of the reasons
other frameworks haven't
done whitespace compression.
Otherwise, we'd have
a tool already that
would be compressing your HTML.
But you can't tell this at
compile time, because it's CSS.
You don't know which
CSS is going to apply.
So when you're compressing
the whitespace,
you can't really tell.
But with the latest
release, we're
giving you a new
component property.
It's called Preserve Whitespace.
If you turn this to
false, it will basically
remove all new lines, all
spaces inside your templates.
And it's quite amazing
how much you can save.
On our material input component,
we went from 40 DOM nodes
down to 17.
There was so much
whitespace in it.
Basically every
single line, you have
that slash new line at the end.
Believe it or not,
that actually generates
a text node behind the scenes.
So that's code size.
And going forward
for performance,
we're primarily
concentrating on two things.
One, strongly typing
everything across Angular--
so a lot of the compiled
code has started using this.
And the nice thing is we don't
have to change the public APIs.
So most of this work
is under the hood.
We're now making Angular
faster and smaller
without affecting
the public APIs.
MATAN LUREY: And leave happier.
FERHAT BUYUKKOTKTEN: Yes.
SPEAKER 1: Very important.
FERHAT BUYUKKOTKTEN: So
the second big change,
which is our surprise
for you today,
is we're introducing a
new way of doing change
detection in Angular today.
So instead of dirty
checking, we're
introducing a mixing class
called component state.
So traditionally, this is
what goes on behind the scenes
if you create a template today.
You have a binding.
And we create this code that
basically checks the new value
against the old value.
And if there was a change,
it updates your template.
However, all the Angular
components by default
are marked as Check Me Always.
So if any event
happens in the system,
it will check all
your components.
And if there is a change, it
will mark the children dirty
if they have property changes.
So there is a lot going
on behind the scenes
to make the zone turn
actually update the templates.
So I have a demo here that shows
you how this works in practice.
So I have a material
table that's
using default change detection.
And as you see, the
table's scrolling.
As it's scrolling, we're
generating new rows on the fly,
as the user is
scrolling on demand.
And if you watch
the frame rate, it's
started dropping from 60
FPS and keeps on dropping.
So this is a real
production table.
So probably 90% of this
code-- one of the architects
is back there that
works on the table.
So this is the actual
production table we use.
And to support all these
future teams inside Google,
we have to build a
really powerful table.
Every single cell here is
actually an Angular component,
because inside apps, you don't
have a fixed set of columns.
The order isn't determined.
Depending on who logs
on to your application,
you might want to show a
completely different table.
So here what we're doing is
the table is completely built.
So when I scroll around,
I expect actually
nothing to happen.
MATAN LUREY:
[INAUDIBLE] changes.
FERHAT BUYUKKOTKTEN: But
if you look at the CPU,
it's maxed out to 100%.
And if you look at one
of these timelines,
it should be very familiar to
you who built very large apps.
So it's basically
doing change detection.
It's going through
the whole tree
and doing change detection,
although the table
at this point is doing nothing.
It's not mutating DOM.
We're just handling
a scroll event.
So what we're introducing today
is basically an easier way
to do OnPush change detection.
So one of the original
designers, Victor Savkin,
designed OnPush And over
the past three months,
we've been working on a way
to make this much, much easier
for you.
So basically you have a
component state mixin,
and you say, as a component,
I know when my state changes.
So Angular, please don't
keep on calling me.
I'm going to let you know when
I want my template updated.
So what you do is you
do a setState call,
and you pass a closure that
actually mutates the state.
And as soon as you
tell Angular setState,
it will come back
and basically change
detect just that component--
that single component
that changed-- and then it
will update your templates.
And if you have
something asynchronous,
like your RPC completing,
you can do the same thing.
You can just say setState
and update model.
So I took the exact same table,
changed about four classes,
and mixed in component state.
And on each input, I
put a setState in there.
And this is the
result. Basically we're
generating about, let's
say, 10 columns, 1,000 rows.
Each cell has actually
two components
to stress it a little bit.
So we have about 20,000
Angular components
being created right now.
And we get consistently 60 FPS.
[APPLAUSE]
So what's even nicer is now
if I go and capture a timeline
and scroll the table
around, it runs some code
and RequestAnimationFrame.
If you have any
sticky headers on top,
it will actually align them.
As you see, the CPU
is totally idle.
This is the type of
timeline you want.
It's these thin hair
lines-- 16.7 milliseconds--
most of that is
completely idle and empty.
So you've got plenty of
space there to run your code.
And we're just getting started
on making Angular Dart faster.
The nice thing is
now that we have
stable APIs and all
these changes in,
we can keep on improving it.
And with that,
I'll turn to Matan.
And he'll talk about how we
do testing with Angular Dart.
MATAN LUREY: All right.
So we have a fast table.
We have all the other fun stuff.
One of the things that
we developed internally,
and we never had in
external version,
was an Angular
Dart specific test
bed for testing
Angular Dart components
for big applications.
There was some testing code.
It worked for some cases.
But it was doing a lot of
fake things behind the scenes.
It was creating fake views.
And you had to hook
everything up together.
So we're using a new model.
We call it NgTestBed.
We're power open
sourcing it today.
And writing a test
with NgTestBed
is actually just right
like writing a Dart test.
It's using package test.
And you're creating a
strongly typed component
called NgTestBed, which is of
type, in this case, Markdown
Component.
You're actually going to
test your Markdown Component.
Again, this is all typed.
You're going to
create a fixture.
A fixture is a running
Angular application.
And when that
component is created,
we're going to call
the text setter-- this
is like a property-- and
assign it this Markdown value.
Next line, we're
just going to expect
that the inner HTML
of the template
has a bolded Hello World.
There's no special
code behind the scenes.
This reads just like
normal Dart code.
And on top of it, this is
entirely using generated code.
This is a AOT test.
We no longer need to
use interpretive tests.
This is all using the same
production code paths.
That's pretty easy
for a simple test.
But when you write
more complicated views,
you don't want to
keep checking, oh,
did the HTML change a little
bit in this way, or what not.
So we have something
we use internally
at Google called Page
Loader, which is also
open source, where
you can actually model
your templates as Dart classes.
It's kind of like
going the inverse.
Angular, you create pub
components to create HTML.
Now we're going to
go the other way.
So this is running
a page object.
There's a code lab actually now
uploaded in Angular 2 examples
showing this exact code.
But in this case, you're
having a selection box.
You might have a selected name
up here and a Confirm button
that when you click
on it, you want
to confirm this is the person.
Maybe this is a
reservation system.
And on the right side
is our Dart class.
So again, it's a pretty
plain Dart class.
It's annotated a little bit.
It's saying that
we have a selection
class called Selection.
And we have a tag called Button,
which is the Confirm button.
And we have two publicly
part of the API, which
is our selected
name and the ability
to click the Confirm button.
So this is your API.
If somebody else
uses your component,
they can actually use
this test infrastructure.
They don't have to
write their own.
And then using a page
object, again, you
use the same NgTestBed.
I have a little bit of
boilerplate at the top
just to show more
about how it works.
But we could hide this for sure.
And we're creating what's
called a new HTML Page Loader.
We're wrapping it around
our test bed fixture.
And then we're adding a
little bit of code to say,
when something
asynchronous happens--
like you click on something,
you type into an input box--
how do we wait for Angular
to say, everything is done.
Now run the next
line of your test.
So it works exactly the same.
You could load an instance
of your page object--
not the component,
but the page object.
And you actually interact
with the component
the same way a user
would, through the DOM.
So here we're going to wait
that the selection was Joe User.
And then we're going to
click the Confirm button.
I have a demo.
We're going to flip
over, and we hope
everything actually works,
because demos always
work at code labs.
Let's see.
I'm using the community
contributed Visual Studio Code
plugin for Dart.
Thank you so much.
And we actually
have here two tests.
We have a test of your
Markdown component--
kind of what you saw before--
a very similar thing.
FERHAT BUYUKKOTKTEN:
Are you able to see?
MATAN LUREY: Do a zoom in?
FERHAT BUYUKKOTKTEN:
Maybe zoom in a little.
MATAN LUREY: Is that better?
FERHAT BUYUKKOTKTEN: Good.
MATAN LUREY: OK.
So we're going to test
our Markdown component.
And we're going to say, when
we decide that Hello World, we
want to see Hello World.
I'm going to go ahead
and pub serve this.
So this is actually my app.
I wrote a little GitHub
viewer for Angular Dart,
just to be able to demo this.
And it uses the GitHub
[INAUDIBLE] API,
and it shows all of the
open issues on Angular Dart.
And it looks like a
couple were added.
Whoops.
FERHAT BUYUKKOTKTEN: Last night.
MATAN LUREY: And you
can click around here.
And you can see the Markdown
rendered of the issues.
And you can go around.
So this is a simple
GitHub viewer.
How do you test this,
is the real question.
This is a pretty
complicated application.
It makes network
calls and renders
with lots of components.
This is actually the
same way I showed before.
So we're going to go over here.
This is my, again, pub serve.
And this isn't super exciting.
But you see the words, Hello
World, and they're bold.
You actually see the result
of your test in NgTestBed.
You can add break points and
see incremental work done.
If you open the
console right now,
you'll see that all tests pass.
This is using package test.
Let's do a more fun one.
This is actually an end-to-end
test of the entire app.
This loads with a
fake GitHub service
and actually clicks
around the screen
is doing assertions that
everything actually worked.
I'll do it one more time
because it's fast-- too fast.
Sorry, Rod.
So we're clicking around.
And if you open your console
again, all tests pass.
And I'm running a search to
make sure that none of my code
breaks maybe the GitHub API
chain-- something like that.
You can also run this with
Pub Run Test on travis,
for example.
So we're going to pub
serve just the test folder.
FERHAT BUYUKKOTKTEN: So
what's awesome is typically
when we try to make a
change in Angular Dart,
we're running about
70,000 targets right now.
So each of those targets
have one, two, 10 tests.
So we have a huge
number of these in use
now inside Google 3.
So that helps a lot
with our stability.
When we make a change,
we're very confident that it
won't break your code,
and it won't break
any of our own production apps.
MATAN LUREY: So we
just passed two tests.
These again are using
the code gen mode.
This is using pub serve to
actually do code generation.
This runs on travis.
You can now validate
that your tests
keep running the same way
they run in production.
You don't have to write really
complicated web driver test,
but you can.
Please.
FERHAT BUYUKKOTKTEN:
So Dart for web--
we think Angular Dart
is a great solution.
Please check it out.
Give us feedback on how
we can further improve it.
And we're looking forward to
seeing what you build with it.
If you have any questions
on Angular Dart,
we'll be around for
the next two days.
Please, come and talk to us.
Thank you.
MATAN LUREY: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]